all right black lives matter movement
took center stage at last night's ESPY
Awards listen I pray for world work I
don't have to fear for my children due
to systemic racism from hundreds of
years of oppression the only thing that
must die is racism black lives matter so
where do we go from here
Seattle Seahawks quarterback Russell
Wilson kicked off the virtual show with
a message about racism and social
injustice in today's world he challenged
his white teammates to lead and not just
listen one of his co-hosts soccer star
Megan Rapinoe praised NFL free agent
Colin Kaepernick's efforts to fight
racism and Gail she isn't the only one
showing cap love and support in an
interview on Sunday
Hall of Famer Bret Favre said Colin
Kaepernick will ultimately be seen as a
hero much in the same way Pat Tillman
was he was the NFL player who left his
lucrative career to join the army after
9/11 and was killed in Afghanistan Gail
I saw that a lot of people rethinking
their feelings about Colin Kaepernick
people say he will it will show that he
was on the right side of history we
shall see he's getting a lot of support